[Music]
Tim she is not sleeping in your bed
these days cuz she's on a vacation with
do you sleep better or worse when she's
gone um I mean of course that's way
better you know I mean I don't have a
problem sleeping regardless the only
thing that really keeps me up is just my
own thoughts and if I have [ __ ] to do
you sleep better alone than with the
person oh yeah oh I sleep way better
when she's around really when there's
one I know there's a presence for some
reason I feel really comfortable relax I
knocked out really well when when I'm in
a hotel like we're doing shows
it actually takes me longer to fall
asleep Oh takes me like 15 minutes
instead of like a minute here's the
thing about it is um I might sleep
deeper because I now after living with
her for a year I'm more aware that I
snore so I always try to sleep on my
stomach to uh so I don't snore as much
too so I don't wake her up
so I'll kind of randomly wake up when
I'm on my bag it should be like oh like
cuz I'm aware of it now like let me not
wake her up and you feel like you're
walking on eggshells a little bit like
you can't really fart it on our next
show like not that deep but just kind of
like if I'm aware of it I'm like oh wait
I don't want to wake her up let me roll
over you know when you're alone is this
no worries I'm gonna snort all night
yeah yeah exactly you know and plus like
have you ever did you ever live alone
yeah okay well [ __ ] I lived alone for so
long and I slept great
yeah so now that she's gone for a week
I'll fine you know I don't really think
Sasa missed the happiest you've ever
been but the thing about is when there's
that presence next to me because she
goes to sleep so early
sometimes I'm more likely to go to sleep
earlier too and as a result get an
earlier sleep cuz when I'm alone I'm
like I'm up on my laptop before I am
just doing [ __ ] right how early like
7:00 she didn't happen she's if she's if
she's still up at like um 11 that's
that's crazy so like 10 she's like me
that's why she looks so healthy yeah I
know her skin's amazing yeah that's the
secret to health why do you ask -
because there's this new psychology
research from the University of British
Columbia that says people sleep better
when they are exposed to their partners
sent overnight so they
getting a better sleep quality so they
did this test where they had
participants have like sleep with shirts
two nights in a row
there was one shirt that was either a
clean shirt or with a stranger sense and
the no stranger said they had like a lot
of things that they had to do like not
wear any scent or not eat particular
food so it doesn't affect their scent
and then so it would be a stranger shirt
and then the next day or whenever it was
it was the their partner shirt and they
discovered through research that they
slept better when they were with their
partners then had a stranger's shirt or
a partnership put it on a pillow and
they sleep with it how they did but they
did sleep with the t-shirt how come half
of these studies sound like something a
stoner came up with could they probably
are stone or students like you know be a
good idea this cost I don't know donate
all of it to the [ __ ] food shelter
hey Aaron holy [ __ ] sounds like a
pheromone test study what does that
ecology test so then they're also the
next thing that they're gonna be looking
into is to see a baby sleep better when
they're they have like their apparent
scent I could have told you well I'm
walking waiting for that one best way to
sleep is if someone lets you bust in
their mouth and then they [ __ ]
picture back like this all [ __ ] night
until you go to sleep
that's what someone oh he said oh it's
relaxing did he say let someone bus in
your mouth he meant to say you someone
lets you but you guys knew what the [ __ ]
I was talking about I did a gentleman
busted someone lets you bust in their
mouth that's what I said
we are you questioning what you save
yourself someone lets you bust in the
mouth yeah yeah that's what I heard
someone let you bust in their mouth
someone let's sleep
we get it they'll use if somebody comes
in here in your face and then someone
lets you bust in their mouth yeah so
does that mean I'm letting them bust in
my mouth oh [ __ ] it anyways you got what
I was saying
what's up what's our womans are
equivalent
what's the woman's equip us thing in the
mouth someone oh okay imagine ladies you
got to [ __ ] bust in a man we look
like pets your back like this while you
go to sleep you got you [ __ ] ten
minutes ago pumpkin go to sleep [ __ ]
such love you relaxing think you're gay
online that's forward you know you two
[ __ ] need to do that if you
goddamn I'm trying to hook your ass up
someone's face until you buzz what is
the woman equivalent of busting into
man's mouths like it's the same thing so
I was like you [ __ ] need to do
that for your women tonight you [ __ ] him
let the boy out there man you busted a
[ __ ] paint you like a [ __ ]
until you go to sleep can we fund this
study I want the [ __ ] University
actually fund this study is it true that
if you bust a no woman's mouth she will
sleep this has everything to do with
shooting baby shut up baby oh my god
you're so romantic
yeah what it is is you gotta do the
experiment right you got a bust in her
mouth with a stranger shirt on and then
busts in her mouth with your shirt on
and if she speaks differently yeah
that's a pop that those are three
opposite so the person that's trying to
sleep they're not doing the work yeah
they're getting the busting wait Joyce
I'll get it I was gonna get crazy
because in your example I was like why
would she do the work and then go to
sleep because she got tired stuck in
that dick all night
yeah that's not fair can you you could
get tired like that but it's better if
you got a happy ending and then you go
to sleep Joe had such a big heart
sometimes what I'm saying that I forget
that he also has a motivational bunch of
courses that people are taking yeah
because you know why the essence to live
in life it's the busting people's mouths
metaphorically yeah yeah yeah you relax
you gotta you gotta you know get your
nut at the end of the day yeah it's
funny that you say that comparing
busting a nut to life right because one
time I was talking about my boy about
how like sometimes when you're jacking
off late at night and you're trying to
find the right porn to like to finally
bus to it's hard you know you're trying
to find the right one so it's for every
age of just you're not sure it's got to
be special so my friend was like um man
sometimes I just I give up I guess it's
hard I just go to sleep cuz I keep so I
just like I just get so fresher I can't
find a guy's gotta sleep I told him I
like you know I dude not me man I keep
going until I bust my nut no matter how
long it takes and he's like damn I think
that's why you so successful I was just
about to say is their work ethic man
commitment a high performer you don't
give up gotta go after your goals that's
inspirational no matter what he gets the
job done he's like you know what I got
to this Tim I'm gonna jerk off more
about getting my goal thank you Tim if I
really really needed to yeah like if I
had to like I'd have to like close my
eyes and focus on some you know the
spank bank as they say but no I
I need something visually to help me I
think most guys are really visual yeah
well it's not HD in my head dude exactly
yeah and then when you imagine yet to do
double the work yeah jacking off and you
gotta think yeah it's better when you
just watch that's not fair wait what's
not fair having to watch and do double
work imagine like it's just so you guys
got it easy with all this [ __ ] man yeah
we just feel it and it feels good and
that's all we need
lucky and they could do multiple times I
know and they could just lay there too
and the multiple times could last like a
long time not just a few seconds and you
don't create a mess after no we don't
sometimes yeah some girls do but you
know it's dumb about this is of course
if you're sleeping next to a [ __ ]
weird person sent you're gonna not sleep
as well sure Oh like even if it's a
clean shirt or the stranger says oh
please you're compared to your part
you're like there's a stranger isn't
that comforting nah man I can knock the
[ __ ] out even when I'm in like a brand
new like hotel room like I can knock but
how humans smell though I hate human
smell so only people I like yeah that's
true well stranger smell strangest know
I hear cuz I'm like you and a part of my
tribe [ __ ] you see I'm like a dog let me
smell your [ __ ] alright you're cool
you're my friend what do you guys do
this all asleep because you're saying
you can fall asleep quickly but does
anyone have trouble sleeping
I don't trust me if you have trouble
sleeping just make a baby jerk off or Oh
what are you saying I get it I get it
oh yeah no that's ex no like have a
physical child made you so tired
yeah on the rare occasion that I can't
sleep I own I pray and whenever I start
praying I fall asleep like a couple
minutes into it and I always feel bad I
apologize to God immediately cuz you
used up to sleep I was going alright Jay
God what's up man you know where this is
going
first of all what was your ASMR first of
all and then you get up there and he's
like just use me to sleep yeah well I I
feel like he's up there like yeah yeah I
know
it's good to hear from you what's going
on I'm saying and then I'm out in like
two minutes he responds to me it's a
one-sided conversation really yeah
you're not talking about is busy talking
to me I started listening to like the
this app that just speaks to us and
tells us like sleep stories of us
talking about God do you guys have it on
the speaker and both you guys keep it so
like on our headboard I have my phone
and okay I could control the volume and
somebody gets too loud from the watch so
we just leave it there but and then
after the meditation or the sleep story
is done then the music continues yeah so
think is nice through the music so if in
the middle of the night cuz I have
trouble sleeping through the night like
I wake up a lot and but if I do then
I'll just start listening to the music
and then I'll start meditating and
that's why not you need a bust in the
mouth is what you like you can see to
pet your back until you go to sleep you
know it doesn't work cuz we do that
every night anyways Oh Jay rested person
on earth apparently know what apparently
was a very well-rested person no I like
the idea that somewhere out there Tim's
friend is trying to Georgia and he's and
he's like nah man quit you're never
gonna get this nut and then he looks
over at a motivational poster he's like
I could do this I can come and then he
does and then he does and my post is
like and then he's made no progress at
all on his life jacking off all day
[Music]